be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly so Nick Fury is kind of a
quagmire in the world of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and so what we're
going to be doing in this video is we're
going to be focusing on Nick Fury behind
the scene so the reason why I say that
is because there's our course of comic
book tie-ins there are the discussions
the events that we've seen over the
course of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as well as a TV show agents of shield
that tell us what it was Nick Fury was
doing and so what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this video while you'll
notice that Nick Fury isn't the most
prominent character in the realm of the
film's proper that behind the scenes
he's probably the single most important
character and so the earliest history of
Nick Fury actually come to the form of a
story called Nick Fury spies like us now
this story largely tells us what it was
Nick Fury was doing at the very early
days of his career during the Cold War
working for the CIA now this story
largely centers around the I guess the
events of Nick Fury and his partner a
man named Escobar and what we learned
here is that Nick Fury and Escobar are
actually tracking down a man named Baron
offski now V Randolph ski was formerly a
CIA informant but apparently he had been
selling bad information and as a result
he was deported from the United States
but during the time of this story Viren
offski has resurfaced and he actually
appeared he apparently has information
on 12 CIA operatives operating within
Russia itself and so what he intends to
do is sell this information to the
government and so the intention of Nick
Fury and Escobar is to intercept Viren
Oski to attain the information or gain
the information from him and take that
information back to the CIA headquarters
but what we learn is that this entire
operation was basically a sting it was
set up by both Nick Fury and Viren
offski as a way to expose Escobar as a
mole or to find out if Escobar was a
mole which is revealed to us when
Escobar actually turns his gun on Nick
Fury stating that he's going to take the
information and sell it to the Russian
government at which point
Escobar is defeated by Nick Fury and
Viren offski and then of course Nick
Fury takes the information back to the
CIA headquarters in in in the United
States now we don't exactly know what it
was it took place between the time that
Nick Fury was working for the CIA and
when it was that he became part of
shield we simply just know that
somewhere along the line this happened
but again if you recall our discussion
about Black Widow what we had talked
about was that around the time that Nick
Fury had become a become the director of
shield basically that he had brought in
Clint Barton he had brought in Hawkeye
and he had tasked Hawkeye with the
assignment of killing Black Widow again
who at the time was one of the foremost
assassins working for the Russian
government and so again as we discussed
in our Black Widow video ultimately
Hawkeye chose not to kill not to kill
Black Widow and instead basically tailed
her learned her identity and then
eventually brought her in to shield
along with Hawkeye himself and so the
result was that the two of them
basically fought alongside and
participated in a series of operations
now after the introduction of Hawkeye
and Black Widow into shield Nick Fury
eventually went on to basically tracked
Bruce Banner to track the Incredible
Hulk
now the comic tie-in that we get for
this actually takes place prior to the
events of the Incredible Hulk film and
so at this point in the in the story or
at this point and the continuity of the
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner has fled
Culver University but he hasn't actually
taken up residence and South America yet
and so what nick fury's intention here
is to basically I guess his intention is
to learn what it was that resulted in
Bruce Banner becoming the Incredible
Hulk what it was that he was doing and
trying to copy the the program or I
guess be a project rebirth system that
had turned Steve Rogers into Captain
America and why it was it taken place
and so what he does is he basically
instigates a situation whereby Bruce
Banner transforms into the Incredible
Hulk
and so what Nick Fury learns here is
that as long as Bruce Banner is left
alone as long as people don't bother him
then he's not really a threat and so
what Nick Fury does is he backs off and
he's simply assigned shield to monitor
Bruce Banner but to never actually
intervene in terms of what it is a Bruce
Banner is doing now
following this we pick up with a Tony
Stark at the beginning of Ironman one
when he had escaped the Middle East or I
guess escaped the the ten rings
and so when he escapes the ten rings
immediately his armor signature pops up
on the radar for shield and Nick Fury is
a little curious at first but he really
just kind of
this time to monitor but putting two and
two together he basically realizes that
Tony Stark had in some former fashion
created a suit of armor that allowed him
to escape and so as a result he sends
phil coulson as a liaison a source for
shield to basically find out what it was
that the Tony Succar been doing what
visit he's currently working on but of
course as we know an Iron Man one Phil
Coulson had been turned down time and
time again by Tony Stark which
ultimately resulted in Nick Fury
appearing to Tony Stark
at the end of Iron Man 1 informing him
at the intention was to bring start on
as part of the Avengers initiative now
the actions of Nick Fury leading up to
Avengers 1 or basically where we get a
lot of stuff with the garson Nick Fury
this I think is probably one of the most
important elements in terms of what does
at Nick Fury has going on behind the
scenes now this story comes in the form
of a six-part series called Fury's big
week now this story initially starts off
with Nick Fury attending to locate Steve
Rogers but being reassigned by the world
security council again the group that is
I guess in charge or that gives Nick
Fury his orders as part of shield but
the world security council had a move
Nick Fury away from trying to find Steve
Rogers and instead tasked him with
devoting the majority of resources for
shield to project Pegasus which again as
we know was the attempt to harness the
power of the tesseract now during this
time Nick Fury followed the orders of
the world Security Council to a degree
but what he also did was basically tell
Phil Coulson to cook the books to make
it look like they're spinning as much
time as they can when in reality Nick
Fury is spending a majority of his time
trying to find Steve Rogers which of
course we know he was successful in
doing with the beginning of Captain
America the First Avenger now during
this week what we also learned was that
when the world security council approved
the Avengers initiative that during the
events of the Incredible Hulk when we
found Emil Blonsky was given the Super
Soldier Serum the intention was to bring
Emil Blonsky
on as as part of the Avengers initiative
in place of the Incredible Hulk but Nick
Fury didn't want to see this happen
and so what Nick Fury did is he sent
Tony Stark to meet with general
Thunderbolt Ross to propose a situation
where the Incredible Hulk would work
with shield which is the reason for the
post-credits scene at the end of a
of the Incredible Hulk film now
following this as we discuss in our
Black Widow video if you recall at the
Ironman one black video a black widow
had been assigned the task of basically
shadowing Tony Stark to monitor him to
keep tabs on him
and so as a result if you recall an Iron
Man to Tony Stark and James Rhodes got
into sort of a fight and when they did
natasha romanoff was actually present
during this conflict and so she had
contacted Nick Fury and told him what
was going on but around the same time
that Nick Fury gets this call from
Natasha Romanoff he's told by one of the
shield scientists that Tony Stark is
dying that palladium is basically
poisoning Tony Stark and so what the
shield ADA or shield scientists do is
they give Nick Fury a vial or I guess an
injection of lithium dioxide which of
course again as we know an Iron Man 2
was designed to curtail the effects of a
plating and poisoning but we also saw
that Nick Fury gave Tony Stark this kind
of motivation this kind of an emotional
bump that he needed to basically step
into the role of being a true and decent
superhero by giving him the message from
his father which of course also
contained the way to combat palladium
poisoning by the introduction of a new
element now after Fury's meeting with
Tony Stark and Iron Man - if you recall
Natasha Romanoff was basically
reassigned by Nick Fury and Phil Coulson
took her place now the reason for this
was because Black Widow was actually
reassigned by Nick Fury to Culver
University and this point in the Marvel
continuity this point in Iron Man 2
coincides with the Incredible Hulk or
with Bruce Banner returning to Culver
University and so Black Widow was
assigned the task of monitoring Bruce
Banner when he arrived at Culver
University and to keep Nick Fury abreast
of any changes anything that may
basically instigate a situation whereby
Bruce Banner turns into the Incredible
Hulk and so at the same time that this
was happening that these two other
things were happening that Hawkeye was
reassigned by Nick Fury to visit New
Mexico to basically keep tabs on the
shield base which basically took place
at the same time that Thor had arrived
to try to reclaim his hammer so again
this is a very very busy situation there
are a lot of things that are happening
in a very short amount of time
and so after the events of Furies big
week because again all that stuff that
we've gone over has taken place in a
single week Nick Fury was successful in
locating Steve Rogers and he basically
has him stationed at the shield
headquarters in New York for recovery
which of course is basically again the
post-credits scene at Captain America
the Winter Soldier where I'm sorryi
Captain America the First Avenger when
we found the Steve Rogers had woken up
and then fled into the city of New York
and was ultimately confronted by Nick
Fury now again following the events of
the Avengers film we pick up with Nick
Fury during the events of Captain
America the Winter Soldier and the
collapse a shield now at the end of
Winter Soldier what we learned was that
Nick Fury was going underground
to attempt to destroy what was left of
Hydra but this was basically expanded on
in agents of shield when Nick Fury
visited Coulson at the end of season 1
providing him with a tool box for all
the things that he would need to
basically bring shield to rebuild shield
but also handing him handing over to him
the position of Director of shield and
so what this does is it ultimately leads
us to the current state of affairs with
regards to Avengers 2 age of Ultron with
that being said I hope that made sense I
know it's a lot to take in but there was
a lot going on with Nick Fury and the
model Cinematic Universe we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
I hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys